-You got some love out there
for Pete Davidson. Yes!
-Very nice.
Thank you. Thank you.
-Dude, welcome back.
You look great, bud.
Good to see you.
-Thanks. Good to see you.
-Congrats on "Bupkis."
I can't wait to talk
about this -- on Peacock.
It's been a year and a half
since I've seen you.
-It's been a bit.
So I'm happy you're back.
-Oh, me too, man.
-Yeah. What have you been up to?
-Well, we got
the show coming out,
and I'm also really excited --
I've been watching, like,
Ryan Reynolds
over the last couple years.
Like, every like six months,
he's just making like
$1 trillion on something.
So I was like,
"I got to do that."
So I had, like, a -- You know, I
just grew up with my mom mostly,
and I had trouble, you know,
shaving my balls.
Like, I would always cut them,
because nobody ever taught me.
I don't know, like, if you're --
I don't know if someone's
supposed to literally be like,
"Let me show you."
But no -- I never had, like,
a father figure to be like,
"This is how you shave
your balls."
So I would always cut my stuff.
And my mom knew, because
I used to live with her
and she did my laundry.
So she would just see, you know,
bloody underwear.
And one --
-[ Laughs ]
-Yeah.
And it, like,
wasn't my sister's.
It was mine.
[ Laughter ]
Hey!
-Whoa. Wow.
-Hey! Hey, whoa, Jimmy!
Hey. That's Rodney Dangerfield,
for anyone in my demo.
No, so, there's this company --
My mom, one Christmas,
got me this thing.
It's called Manscaped.
It's, like, a -- She put it
under -- in my stocking, like,
and she did it, like, the way,
like in "A Christmas Story"
when they're like,
"I think there's one
more present, like, over there."
And I opened it,
and it was these ball trimmers
and they're magnificent.
Haven't trimmed my balls
since pandemic.
And I called the company,
and they were like,
"You could do --
We will do stuff."
So I brought you one.
It's a Manscaped...
This is where I use --
-Thank you very much.
-You can use it for your face.
I fully charged it.
It has a flashlight.
-It's got a light on it.
-These are lights so you can see
how awful your penis is.
-[ Laughing ] Oh, my God.
-Not yours, just, you know,
penises in general.
Terrible.
-Yeah.
-But, yeah, I thought --
You know,
I just wanted you to have it.
It's great.
-That's so nice of you.
You don't have to
bring me gifts.
-No, I got you one
ordered for you,
but it didn't come in time,
so that one's mine.
But I washed it, and...
-I went to a barbershop
and I just dipped it
in that blue [bleep]
and then I --
-Oh, I know that blue --
-I put it in the blue stuff
next to the Clubman gel.
-That cleans everything.
-Yeah, yeah.
It cleans everything.
-That cleans everything.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Gosh, I forgot
what question I asked you,
but welcome to the show.
-Oh, thank you, guys.
-I'm so happy you're here.
Pete, I missed you, bud.
This is exactly
why I love talking to you.
You're hosting
"Saturday Night Live"
next weekend.
-Yeah.
-This is what I'm talking about.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is what I'm talking about.
Full circle, buddy.
-Very exciting.
Yeah, I mean, it's really funny.
You know, Lorne told me
a couple months ago,
but then, this week,
they're like --
You know, as you know,
the writers strike might happen.
-Oh, that's right.
-So I've been working on this
for like 2, 3 months,
and they're like,
"Yeah, well, we'll know Monday
if it's happening or not."
-It might not happen.
-It might not.
-Please take care of
the writers.
-But it just feeds -- It sucks,
because it just feeds my, like,
weird story I have in my head.
Like, "Of course
that would happen to me."
-"They did that."
-Yeah.
-"They didn't want me to host
'Saturday --'"
-They didn't want me to --
It's all about me.
-Yeah.
-So, we don't know.
But if it happens,
I'm super-excited.
Lil Uzi Vert's
the musical guest.
But it would be really cool.
-Who...
-Lil Uzi Vert.
-Lil Uzi Vert is fantastic!
-Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's cool.
-Are you nervous about hosting?
What are you looking forward
to -- seeing everybody again,
the crew?
-I'm terrified,
because I went there to, like,
hang out just to say hi.
There's a lot of
new guys and gals,
and everyone's --
And they're very excited.
Remember when you first get it,
and you're just like,
"Oh, my God!
That's Jim Carrey."
And then like two years into it,
you're like,
"[Bleep] that's Jim Carrey."
Like, you went --
No, he's the best.
I'm just saying, like,
you know, you're like,
"Oh, I have to, like,
be on my A-game,"
but you lose the whole like,
"Oh my God, oh, my God."
You're like, "Oh, my God.
I got to come up with a sketch
where I'm dressed as a cucumber"
or something, you know?
So --
-I've done that sketch before.
-But I went there.
I stayed the whole show.
That show is -- It's hard.
-Yeah, right?
-I had a weird little gig there,
because, like,
I would just do my thing
once in a while,
and they would,
like, let me do whatever.
But I was like,
"You guys work really hard."
-"This is a lot of work."
-I was like, "I'm being
more than like one sketch.
That's crazy."
-But when you're in there,
though -- Yeah, exactly.
When you're in there,
if you get one sketch on,
you go, "Whew!
That was a lot."
-Yeah.
But I immediately
got nervous, though.
I was like,
"Oh, this is crazy."
-Did Lorne call you to
offer you to like,
"Would you like to host?"
-I got the Lorne call.
It was really cool.
-How does that differ
than the call
telling you
that you're on the cast?
-It was exactly the same
as it was 10 years ago.
I swear.
He called me and he was like --
I remember he was very sweet.
He was like, "I'm not really
sure what to do with you,
but I believe in you,
and let's figure it out."
You know?
Yeah, that was my get to --
for asked to, like --
my big call ever.
Like, it was --
-"We're not sure what to do --"
-Yeah, he was like,
"We're not sure,
but I believe in you,
and we'll see."
And I was like, "Alright."
-At least he's honest.
-Yeah, honest.
And he was right, you know?
And then the same kind of call.
He was like,
"I want you back to host.
And, you know,
you've done it before,
and the cast will help, so..."
[ Laughter ]
"But it will be happy
for you to be home."
-That sounds so real,
by the way.
-He's the best.
-That's not a joke.
That's exactly what
he would say.
-Lorne has bars.
Lorne says,
like, the coolest stuff ever.
-Oh, I know.
-I almost want to just, like --
I have to bring a pen and paper
every time I go,
'cause he'll say something.
-One time, me and Lorne
and Judah Miller,
who created "Bupkis" with me,
and Dave Sirus and Jason Orley,
great writers and director --
we were all on a plane
going to meet Pesci,
and he goes -- He just turns
over to Judah and goes,
"Here's some notes
about 'Bupkis'
from 30,000 feet above the sky."
And you're just like,
"That's the coolest thing
I've ever heard."
-Yeah, how do you
just say stuff like that?
-Yeah.
He just has gems all the time.
-I was so happy when I
heard about "Bupkis" starting.
I love the title, by the way,
because you go,
"This is bupkis."
-It's whatever.
-It's whatever, yeah.
-That's what my grandpa
would say when I was growing up.
He would just say,
"You know bupkis."
It means "nothing" in, like,
you know, Yiddish or whatever.
-Your co-stars are
Edie Falco and Joe Pesci.
-How about that?
-Buddy!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on!
-Pretty cool.
-Doesn't get much better.
-It's like a fever dream.
I'm stoked, man.
-Doesn't get much better
than that.
How'd you get them to do this?
-I have no --
Edie was shockingly
just so on board
from the beginning.
We were so nervous --
-But Joe kind of retired
from acting.
-Yeah, so, Lorne --
We were trying to find someone,
and Lorne called and he was
like, "What about Pesci?"
And he said it so casually,
like the guy works all the time,
and, you know, famously
has only done "The Irishman"
in the last like 20 years,
because he's --
You know,
he doesn't need to act anymore.
-No.
-And Lorne dropped
one of his bars and he was like,
"All an actor needs
a good part."
And you're like --
Yeah, hanging out with
Lorne is like being
in, like, an A24 movie all day.
So -- Where it's just,
like, stings and, like, jolts,
and then, like,
you're in an outfit
and you're
getting shot out of cannons.
-Yeah.
-It's crazy.
He's a crazy, cool man.
-What were they like
to be around?
I mean, did it up
your acting game?
-I hope so.
I mean, that's why I was like --
You know,
this was interesting to cast,
because I was like,
you know, it's a specific show.
It's about me.
So, like, if you don't like me,
like, that alienates,
like, a lot of the audience.
So I literally casted people
that everybody loves.
So if you hate me, you're like,
"Oh, there's Joe Pesci.
It's fine."
You know what I mean?
"Oh, Edie Falco."
-I think we love you.
I think a lot of people
love you.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, thank you, guys. I'm stoked.
-Can I run through some other
guest stars that's in "Bupkis"
that you can check out?
There's Ray Romano, Jon Stewart,
John Mulaney, Steve Buscemi,
Bobby Cannavale, Charlie Day,
Brad Garrett, Sebastian Stan,
Method Man.
How did you pull off
all these --
-I just called everyone.
I just -- It's really weird.
Like, a lot of people just don't
talk to each other.
Like, remember, like, when
you did -- You were so nice.
Jimmy was nice enough to do
this Garden benefit we did,
and they were trying to get,
like, a list of people.
And I was like,
"What about Jimmy Fallon?"
They're like, "Oh, I don't know
how I can possibly --"
I was like,
"His office is next to mine.
I could --
You know, and I was like --
-And you just asked me.
-And he was nice enough
and came out.
So I think people don't do
that much, and they should,
because people want
to work with people.
So I just called people
that I thought were cool
and always were nice to me,
and they showed up.
-Ray Romano and Brad Garrett.
It's like an "Everybody Loves
Raymond" reunion.
-Ray is the best,
and he had a blast.
And we had Ray in one of them,
and at the end of it,
he had a really good time
and he was like, "You know,
I never would,
you know, ever..."
It's a horrible impression.
-No.
No, you got to save this
for Saturday.
-It's not fair.
It's like doing,
like, a Walken or whatever.
It's just like everybody
has a Ray Romano.
He was so sweet,
he had a good time,
and he was like, "You know,
I love this episode.
I love being in one."
He goes, "It'd be pretty crazy
if I showed up in another."
And I was like, "Do you
wanna --" Yeah, I was like,
"I'll do it right now."
He's like, "Eh, you know,
it's not my show.
I'm just, like, saying..."
-And then he did.
He did three of them.
He's the man.
He's the coolest guy.
Also, check out his movie --
"Somewhere in Queens"
just came out.
It's murdering.
-It's actually fantastic.
It's great, yeah.
-It's so incredible.
I have one funny "Pesch"
story for you, though.
-Yeah, tell me.
-Because Pesch doesn't --
I'm very private about him,
because he's
a sweet, private man.
But there's one thing
I want everybody to know that.
So, you know, he's very nice.
If you're nice, he's nice.
-Yeah, of course.
-But, you know,
he tries to keep to himself,
unless you're a kid and you
recognize him from "Home Alone."
And this is something he did.
And, obviously, I am a big
"Home Alone" guy, too,
so I got to see this.
If there was ever a kid that
noticed him as his character,
he would go up to them
and he would go,
"Listen, kid."
He goes, "You better be good
to your parents this Christmas,
because if you don't,
me and my pal Marv
are going to come find you."
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Love you, Joe Pesci!
-Yeah. Yeah.
And then -- Yeah.
And then the kid would
be like, "Oh, my God."
And then he would
look back at me and go.
That's Pesch, yeah.
-That's Pesch right there.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Pete Davidson
and Joe Pesci in "Bupkis."
Take a look at this.
-Yep.
-I don't want to do this.
-I know you don't want
to do it.
Who the [bleep]
would want to do it?
But just do it. We're here.
You want to ruin
boys' night now?
-No. What --
Boys' night is over.
-No, it's not over.
-I took you guys out to dinner.
We had a nice time.
Roy got half laid.
It's over.
It's time to go home.
-This is your chance to really
do something for somebody,
make somebody else
[bleep] happy,
instead of yourself
all the time.
-Yeah, I meant, like --
I don't know --
watching the game together,
not helping your friend
[bleep] a prostitute.
-You can do it, Peter. Do it.
-Roy, are you sure
this is what you want?
-You'd be doing me a mitzvah.
-There's your answer.
I know you don't want to do it,
but just [bleep] do it.
-Alright, come on, let's go.
-There you go. Let's do it.
-There you go.
-Pete Davidson.
All episodes of "Bupkis" will
premiere on Peacock May 4th.
More with Pete after the break.
Come back, come back.